you know what I couldn't believe I was
flipping through the book and I I think
I had heard this somewhere but I'd
forgotten it
we have a young crowd they may not know
what the WPA was but during the
Depression the government set up a lot
of public works and the WPA put an ad in
the newspaper that was you know helping
young actors get started
free acting class free acting classes
and you saw this ad WPA sponsored
theater classes you could go and you
could tell yeah at 40 at the 100 Center
Street and I went down there my brother
I would not be an actor if it wasn't for
the government they some people in the
government say get the people off the
government's back well that's what we
belong yeah especially when there's
times of strife and so if I didn't go to
that class I wouldn't be sitting here
today and I'll never forget my first day
in that class Oh mrs. Whitmore a very
old distinguished English actress and
said children we're not going we're
going to do with soliloquy from Hamlet
but not one of the major saloon who is
we're going to all do boys and girls
Queen Gertrude speech on the death of
Ophelia and if you wake me up in the
middle of the night and asked me to
recite it I can do that
it's not amazing the stuff from that
long ago I have the same thing I
remembered my first speech that I had to
give in a play was they cast me as Santa
Claus I think in the second grade and I
had a long speech to give that all had
to rhyme and I memorized it if you wake
me up at 3:00 in the morning I can say
it today I can't remember anything else
but I can remember that it's a it's an
amazing thing the human mind there is a
willow grows aslant a brook that shows
his hoar leaves in the glassy stream
there with fantastic Garland's as you
come crow flowers nettles daisies and
long purples that liberal Shepherds give
a grosser name but our cold maids do
dead man's fingers call them they're
worth a coordinate clambering to hang
and then be a sliver broke went down her
weedy trophies and herself fell in the
weeping Brook her clothes spread wide
and mermaid-like awhile say bore her up
at which time she chanted snatches of
old tunes as one incapable of error
distressed until a garments heavy with
drink pulled the poor wretch from a
melodious lay to muddy death
I want to say as impressed as I was but
the fact you could remember it all the
facial expression didn't sound too sad
about you yeah I just this for you for
me and you when I was a young actor I
did a Shakespearean tour we were told to
learn fourth fourth plays as you like it
I play to Orlando and TIFF ellipse of
Everson the comedy of arrows and and I
was supposed to play Claudius in Hamlet
and something in Taming of the Shrew and
and we've did all three plays one-night
stands and I had not learned my learns
in for Claudius because it wasn't coming
up four months later somebody called in
and said we need we had Taming of the
Shrew last week we need Hamlet and you
know the lines and all my lines I stayed
up all night and learn my lines and I
know this is an impression of what I did
on stage Laertes is waiting offstage for
his cue and I say when sorrows come they
come not single spies but in battalions
the people muddied in their thoughts for
poor Polonius is dead
Dutton the very throes of tram at all
that picked upon the stain stalls and
qoodles men chattering and this with the
valley calls of Fram it'll say upon the
fall break forth the farmers being the
drama's falling multitudinously define a
new boy
that's all gibberish what you see what
happened that night is just what
happened now the people applauded wait
and I was so embarrassed the next I
stayed up all night and learned it you
learn and did it for word-for-word yeah
that is not No and I realized I'm a
better writer than the drink
you